how important is the chemistry between
these two and how did you know you would
haven't what you don't I mean and you
said something really interesting the
other day is you don't even I mean you
can feel it between you but you don't
know that it's necessarily been captured
I mean that's your responsibility
and so it's it's something you just have
to take that gamble on but um I mean
I've long my Rooney's choices as an
actress and not only the types of roles
but the choices she makes internally
within a character and so I thought
there's potential it's about you know
situations and that starts with the
novel and that comes through the
beautiful adaptation that I first read
of Phyllis's but words they don't have a
language for the feelings that they're
experiencing and that's true for this
particular historical moment it's true
for lesbians in the 50s clearly but it's
also what I when I read it for the first
time I just felt like that's true for
anybody who's falling in love and who is
into Reza's shoes is you feel like you
know it's unclassifiable what you're
feeling and no one's ever been there
before you you know and that you're
inventing it as you go along and so
there was something both intensely
specific about that but also incredibly
Universal about that I just thought that
was such a beautiful idea so we really
went with it and I feel like everybody
was on the same page about a level of
restraint and understatement and that's
true all the way through to the score
where I really feel like discussions
that you and I had about the score and
different themes that you would bring to
me at different stages we kept realizing
that some of the simplest you know most
understated melodic elements in the film
ultimately had the most impact but it
sounds like the score was kind of
crucial to filling in some of those gaps
as well you know the silences and and
the feelings well it's a great canvas
for a composer because of all of the
space and because so much is unsaid it
still leaves the question how much does
the music want to say about what's going
on mostly I try not to get ahead of
the actors of the characters of what
they're feeling and experiencing and but
still you know treated very subjectively
from their point of view and also
there's there's a scene toward the end
where you really build to an amazing
crescendo is that was that a tough one
for you um
well of course at that point we already
built so much structure you know that
that if that didn't work made something
had been wrong earlier on honestly but
it's a great it's a great moment and it
was handed to me by you know Phyllis and
by Todd by not having any dialogue in
the climax of the movie it's an amazing
opportunity and and the way Todd has
chosen to end it with the cut to black
is is very bold and I just I tried to be
as bold in the in the scoring so one of
the things that goes on is is that the
sex scene is a very crucial kind of
thing and you're very restrained there
and talk about the delicacies of making
that work and how important it was to
the film well it's you know the
restraint is important but it also had
to be a common ative you know shifting
moment in the movie and the film is in
many ways although it falls outside the
the mystery writing or the thriller over
of Patricia Highsmith's other novels it
is a suspense film in that you're
waiting to see how and when this desire
and this love could ever be consummated
and how that could happen at this
particular time historically and what
are the rules and what are the
guidelines and what what's going to
happen on the road when they're when
they're sort of freed from their
respective worlds in the film I I push
the notion of Abby's involvement in
Carol's life even further than the novel
had in terms of the the bonds between
women female friendship is very
important to this and the way that the
women help each other they are isolated
but they're isolated together in in in
their own ways and this
incredibly poignant and repressive
environment so Kayden Rooney what kind
of research did you do into the rules of
the period and the ways that your
characters were locked down and and
inhibited by those rules well obviously
I mean it's a Highsmith and this time
the criminal act is the love between the
women and that existed then and doesn't
exist in most english-speaking countries
in most of the Western world at the
moment so that's a huge difference and
like any great drama you need a big
impediment you know to get over and that
certainly was one but I found
whenever you're investing in the period
it's you don't want it to be locked its
meaning to be locked up solely as a
museum piece and what I really loved was
when we got to Cincinnati and many got
got down to with tardis that he really
introduced the female gaze of the 50s
and all these hitherto unknown to me
female photographers so we were looking
at 50 that the 50s from a female
perspective a lot of whose work was
buried and Vivian Maier coincidentally
at the time we were shooting that
wonderful documentary which was
nominated had just been released about
her and was wonderful material to watch
a Malaysian to this so it was it was to
me it was looking in at the 50s with an
entirely different lens a very sort of
emotional personal romantic but
tumultuous lens and like life in
reflection you know in New York so it's
also hard for us to realize how much
fear there was there then and the kind
of what were these two characters afraid
of I'm not sure exactly what Torres was
afraid of I mean I don't know that she
was afraid of things in society
necessarily I think she was afraid of
continuing her life on the path that she
was on because I think she you know at
the start of the film she has this
boyfriend who seemingly is perfect in a
group of friends and this job but she
feels very much alone in her life and
very unfulfilled and so I think she's
afraid of sort of letting herself go
down that road because it's sort of the
easy
your path I think like all great love
stories there's not will ceases to be
part of it you're compelled for reasons
that and you're not entirely conscious
of to to move towards someone it's like
you're being pushed by an invisible
force which is part of the thrill and
part of the terror you know of it they
both both characters say at different
points in the film I'm not afraid and
and I think that what you're afraid of
when you're in love when you're in the
dark is that the other person doesn't
feel the same way in return but once you
learn that they do then you're no longer
afraid of anything
what they're not afraid of is their
sexuality which is is is radically
different from most of the literature of
the period the Pulp Fiction and and the
lesbian literature that preceded it and
that was one of the things that I think
attracted all of us also the notion of
motherhood and what makes a responsible
proper mother was something that
certainly fascinated me and it seemed
very forward thinking of Pat Highsmith
to come up with these things in the
early 50s so I'm also fascinated by the
looks that the two of you put together
with costume designer Sandy Powell so
Carol is so glamorous and so beautiful
that was to been really fun to put
together but we're women of her class
like that every day that beautiful that
elegant that put together I think life
was slower so you have time for a better
blow-dry but there was it was a we
talked about it a lot because as Todd
says the first section of the film
Carol's is an object of desire and so
you wanted to create this sort of
mysterious unknowable ambiguous object
of desire
it was almost impenetrable so that you
then could break through the carapace of
that to sort of find out what was
underneath and that the cracks were in
fact quite
large and I love the fact that you know
sort of as a metaphor the the fur coat
that we decided was the one to use was
continually falling apart you know we
only had one and that's that's a
testament to Sandi is that she is I mean
she's the my opinion Jersey Edith head
of her day but there she was every cent
between every take personally sewing up
the coat you know she's no no job too
small Rooney you put together this
fabulous gumming look which some of us
think is Audrey Hepburn but maybe it's
gene Simmons tella tell us what you put
together what's Rooney Mara right I
didn't I didn't put it together that was
all sandy costumes are always super
important to me and I usually am very
loud and opinionated about them but
there was no need for that with Sandy I
I don't think there was one thing I went
in and tried on that that didn't feel
right for it
yeah Torres's clothes are very different
from Carol she did not she does not have
time for a better blow-dry you know they
were very loved very worn in she doesn't
have that many pieces so I you know we
mixed and matched things and I think my
clothes they were not as refined but
they were much more comfortable but in
audience I mean an audience starts to
read meaning obviously as soon as a
character walks on the screen and I mean
there's many many impediments to move
the women consummating their desire for
one another and and a large one was the
you know that the socio-economic
difference and so we wanted to visually
obviously represent that and also mark
the change that Rooney makes as a
character that she literally is growing
up in front of your eyes to the course
of this film and transforming